il a eu une année incroyable michael
bryce et le garde du corps de l'année
est ce que c'est un parent à vous
certainement pas naïve kincaid est un
tueur à gages recherchés pour des
milliards de meurtre et vous faites
souvent ce rêve juste une fois alors si
par nuit d'accord vous devriez peut-être
faire une pause
[Musique]
je suis en congé sabbatique et
franchement
je sais pas pourquoi je n'y ai pas pensé
plus tôt
[Musique]
c'est comme si le monde entier attendait
que j'arrive à évoluer pour la première
fois je commence à imaginer ma vie sans
protéger celle des autres c'est vraiment
un
on se connaît tous la mafia a enlevé mon
mari tué les faucons à issoire n'est pas
question que je m'applique j'ai des
consignes thérapeutiques très strict
j'ai promis à ma psy d'arrêter plus
garde rapprochée
ça veut dire pas d'arbre ou a pas de
meurtre et pas de sens
qu'est ce qu'il faut ici lui
c'est une bombe lacrymo je suis en congé
aaa
combien de fois j'ai failli me faire
tuer
[Musique]
pas assez haut
venait d'avoir un bébé c'est quoi ce bon
je serai pas une super maman franchement
c'est bien sûr un enfant serait
tellement chanceux de grandir pour ton
ventre
[Musique]
falloir tout nous raconter je pouvais
aller vous faire
moi de mon côté je dirai tout ce que je
sais